la réunion est doté d'un paysage
incroyable ici le sublime est au rendez
vous le littoral les montagnes et même
les volcans lille est tout naturellement
une formidable aspiration pour les
réalisateurs de films et de
documentaires pour capturer au mieux cet
environnement un des meilleurs caméraman
au monde a fait le déplacement
il est spécialisé dans les prises de vue
aériennes sa présence il la doit aussi à
l'une des épreuves sportives les plus
difficiles au monde
il devra film est vu du ciel le grand
raid de la réunion une traversée de
l'île par les sites les plus
inaccessibles en moins de 65 heures
cette course se déroulera sur environ
150 km de long imaginez-vous enchaîné
quatre marathons classique avec plus de
8700 mètres de dénivelé soit
l'équivalent de 60 tours eiffel dans les
jambes au départ de saint philippe
tout au sud ils seront plus de 2000
concurrents et près d'un quart d'entre
eux n'atteindront jamais la ligne
d'arrivée la diagonale des fous
son surnom est un défi incroyable avant
de filmer la course basse et son
hélicoptère nous invite à la découverte
d'un parcours exceptionnel
bienvenue au coeur de la réunion dans le
sanctuaire de l'exploit
[Musique]
3 heures du matin dans un entrepôt au
sud de l'île on s'affaire à monter un
matériel qui fait rêver tous les
réalisateurs une caméra nouvelle
génération est à parier sur un
hélicoptère
la caméra est l'une des plus
perfectionnés au monde elle offre des
images d'une prodigieuse qualité et sa
stabilité dans les airs et sans
concurrence
c'est cet homme qui va s'en servir il
était la réunion pour couvrir la course
du grand raid
et lui c'est l'un des cameramans les
plus demandés au monde s'est écroulé la
bicyclette la première fois c'est très
très dur mais après quelques années tu
arrives adolescents
lassiné flex c'est la crème des caméras
son prix est à la hauteur de ses
performances
plusieurs millions de dollars une bonne
partie de la nuit sera nécessaire pour
que tout soit installée et au petit
matin base sera déjà dans son
hélicoptère l'île de la réunion offre un
spectacle à couper le souffle
dans cet océan indien les lumières ici
n'existe nulle part ailleurs
quand le grand raid s'est mise en place
bah c'est sa caméra sont devenus
indispensables pour filmer au mieux les
coureurs
[Musique]
maintenant à décoller du bon à
l'intérieur des machines aucune attache
est grand pur a bien aux oreilles rien
décollage
le parcours que vont emprunter les
coureurs du grand raid est l'un des plus
extraordinaires qui soit la première
étape de saint-philippe au volcan est
loin d'être monotone
peu à peu la végétation se raréfient la
température descend de quelques degrés
la montée est éprouvante mais la
récompense se situe au bout des
chaussures les raiders fous vont
pénétrer l'univers du volcan alors que
la foule va s'étirer pas à pas sur un
paysage lunaire la réunion posée au beau
milieu de l'océan indien est issu d'un
point chaud sorti des eaux
il y a trois millions d'années depuis ce
jour elle n'a cessé d'évoluer et
aujourd'hui le tiers de ce décor est
encore intacte et préserver de la
colonisation humaine
le grand raid va nous faire découvrir ce
bout de terre
véritable laboratoire vivant à l'humeur
volcaniques
[Musique]
imaginez une éruption volcanique
gigantesque arrivé tout droit du centre
de la terre la réunion contrairement à
sa grande soeur madagascar n'est pas
issu d'une fracture continental c'est la
lave qui l'a façonnée depuis plus de
cinq millions d'années au fond de
l'océan indien
aujourd'hui encore le piton de la
fournaise est l'un des volcans les plus
actifs de la planète
fascinant mais aussi effrayant beaucoup
d'habitants le redoute et pourtant
chaque année ils sont des dizaines de
milliers à venir contempler son
spectacle
[Musique]
le haut
la coulée de lave est encore vivante sa
chaleur et de 800 degrés à 30 mètres de
profondeur
elle bouge elle vibre à chaque seconde
en attendant le réveil de son géniteur
sa vie toujours écouler sans la forte
température à faible profondeur je
penserai ouais bah vu d'abord là
l'aspect juvénile de la coulée donc qui
a seulement 17 mois et puis le fait que
et ben la cool et très très épaisse
l'ensemble des coulées très épaisse et
ce basalte qui garde la chaleur très
longtemps on a là un ensemble de coulée
qui va mettre plusieurs années à
refroidir complètement en cours ce dif
lit-on ce petit relief qui sort qu il
était il ivre elle en gros quand même
faudra comparer avec les photos qu'on à
l'île de la réunion et est une île
volcanique donc qui s'est formée
uniquement par l'empilement des
matériaux volcaniques
depuis le plancher océanique qui à 4000
mètres de fond
on va dire son histoire a commencé en
gros au niveau du plancher il ya 5 6
millions d'années il lui a fallu un
temps très long pour arriver en surface
bien sûr puisque c'est cette dimension
considérable et les premières là va
émerger sont apparus il ya un peu plus
de deux millions d'années
est ce que les gens savent pas trop
peut-être c'est que le piton de la
fournaise en fait est très ancien on
pense qu'il a au moins 700 mille ans au
niveau de son activité aérienne voire
peut-être un million d'années et pendant
donc on va dire 700 800 mille ans les
deux volcans fonctionner en même temps
le piton des neiges et puis tant la
forme
michel sicre et à labarrère sont des
amoureux du volcan qu il se rende de
temps en temps sur la coulée de lave de
2007 un endroit strictement interdite au
public
des zones entières peuvent s'effondrer
et la chute dans certaines provinces
provoquerait une mort certaine dû à la
chaleur
là on est sur des laves en plaques
on voit qu'elles sont complètement
aplati jointes et par des fissures quand
on marche dessus ça ça craque un peu ça
bouge et en fait ya des espaces en
dessous donc il ya un certain danger de
passer à travers de traverser et le
danger il est encore plus haut niveau
dès ornitho donc c'est ces petits cônes
de projection qui se sont formés quand
un gros tunnels de lave s'est crevé au
moment de l'éruption donc la lave est
sorti sous pression à cet endroit là et
l'alignement de ses ornitho en fait et
bien des limites
un gros tunnel qui est en dessous donc
il faut éviter d'aller au tour de passer
entre parce que ça risque éventuellement
de s'effondrer mais à certains endroits
on peut supposer que c'est solide mais
par contre bas en dessous il ya du vide
quoi
[Musique]
écoute faut pas passer entre les deux
regards alors c'est dangereux là tout ça
est creux quoi écoutons fait on passe
pas par là par contre bon ben ouais si
on peut y aller éventuellement mais
pareil c'est quand même des des blacks
un regard d'un plus ça fait stella aller
on va contourner beaucoup plus haut
difficile de concevoir la vie dans ces
roches volcaniques figé pourtant au
milieu des rochers la verdure symbole de
naissance fait son apparition et nous
avançons en partie se décomposer
produire des éléments organiques qui
vont se mélanger aux minéraux et crée
donc un début de sol et ce début de
soldes favoriser dans l'installation
d'autres végétaux et au entre 3 ans et
10 ans après l' après la mise en place
de la cool et on voit apparaître des
colonies de fougères et ainsi de suite
les fougères vont préparer un sol un peu
plus riches on peut imaginer donc d'ici
deux cents à trois cents ans on aura ici
à la place de ces coulées de lave une
forêt on va contourner un peu on va
contourner un peu parce que tu vois
garda ça ces fonds c'est notre histoire
c'est l'histoire de l'humanité c'est
l'histoire de la planète c'est
l'histoire de des êtres vivants d' de
son façonnage de sa colonisation c'est
c'est tout ça en condensé géographique
et temporelle en fait on ressent le
contact direct avec cette nature dont on
fait partie dont on dépend et d'où on
vient et ça et ça c'est phénoménal comme
[Musique]
le piton de la fournaise que lui n'a
2008 132 m sa particularité c'est cet
immense plaine noir la plaine des sables
un lieu magique et envoûtant pour les
coureurs de la diagonale et à quelques
kilomètres à vol d'oiseau on n'oublie
pas la proximité de l'océan
[Musique]
les coureurs vont alors quitté les
paysages lunaires de la plaine des
sables et entameront la deuxième étape
de la diagonale des fous ici la
végétation et rabougri mais elle
s'intègre parfaitement dans ce décor
grandiose qui s'étend à perte de vue
au loin se dessine le piton des neiges
pâturages paysages variés des hautes
plaines forêts primaires typique des
zones humides d'altitude les raiders
affronteront l'as des grands morceaux du
parcours
l'ascension de cet ancien volcan point
culminant de la course à 2485 m ce n'est
qu'après 60 km que les coureurs
rejoindront le cirque de cilaos et sa
forêt aux nombreuses essences la
végétation ici et exubérante
elle s'est implantée peu à peu dans les
rochers de la réunion cette croissance
exceptionnelle de la nature a été
favorisée par le transport des graines
dans les courants marins et à la force
des cyclones
[Musique]
voter parce que très bien sinon les
petits zannier de cilaos ont une
réputation qui dépasse les frontières de
la réunion ils ont acquis de génération
en génération à savoir faire unique pour
extraire le meilleur des fleurs et des
plantes de leurs forêts combien de des
teasers comme ça ils déballent dépend
pour quoi tu viens vraiment quoi mais si
tu veux faire chacune complications
mélanger note israël comme en mai après
dépend éclaté sur le guardian ou ne vont
pas des tisanes jamais fait ça en
confiance et que la pièce pour
tranquillement ya des progrès à
plusieurs longueurs littoral même dans
les halls à plusieurs fois les mêmes
noms et la fouace et par la même porte
où les gens ils peuvent encore les
points comme ça des fois les mêmes leur
nourrice que le plan b si mais c'est pas
la même espèce si la hausse est l'un des
endroits les plus féeriques de la
réunion comme ses frères voisin mafate
et salazie ce cirque est né suite de
grand effondrement géologiques et des
glissements de terrain
ici la nature fait encore la loi et la
faune et la flore sont encore préservés
au lieu de la biodiversité mondiale
on y trouve certaines variétés
spécifiques à lille
voilà ici on se trouve dans un habitat
complètement naturel composé d'espèces
indigènes endémique des espèces qui
existent qu à la réunion savoir que les
espèces indigènes sont des espèces qui
va arriver par leurs propres moyens sur
l'île et parmi ces espèces 30% sont
endémiques strict de la règion données
n'existent qu'à la réunion
alors c'est vrai qu'à la réunion on a
quand même une spécificité on parle
souvent de pour les arbres de bois de
pieds de bois on a un bois darnet tout
bois de reinette parce que les feuilles
quand on est froide souvent sentent un
peu la pomme
là on a encore un voix de remparts donc
c'est des espèces quand même assez
caractéristique de ce type de milieu
alors là on voit en un autre bois 1
boîte qui vit qui aussi typique de ces
forêts de basse altitude avec des
feuilles différentes
lorsqu'elles sont jeunes ils donc là on
voit elles sont étroites et lorsqu'elles
sont adultes elles sont sont des
feuilles entières ces faits juvénile qui
sont étroits tout petit c'est pour
éviter de aux herbivores devenir les
manger quand ils sont tout petits
ça s'est passé c'est pas très attirant
pour un herbivore et en même temps il ya
une autre théorie qui paraît aussi
probable à cette altitude
c'est d'éviter trop débarque pour
transpiration ça permet de mieux
s'adapter à la sécheresse cours entre
des falaises impressionnantes et de
sublimes forêt personne ne reste
insensible à cette nature et la beauté
du site regorge aussi d'histoire celle
du peuple réunionnais les montagnes que
vous voyez derrière moi en loin cette
crête s'appelle la crête du dimitile
dimitile était justement le nom d'un
chef marron qui vivaient dans ces zones
là et dimitile en malgache ça veut dire
le guetteur donc justement ils
choisissent elles avaient choisi
probablement
un endroit stratégique pour observer
l'ensemble du sud y compris à
l'intérieur du cirque pour repérer les
chasseurs d'esclaves puisque l'époque
des grandes plantations et bien il y
avait les maîtres qui mandate est des
chasseurs d'esclaves pour venir chasser
entre guillemets les esclaves en fuite
dans les montagnes l'histoire des
ancêtres de la réunion se poursuit
encore aujourd'hui dans les montagnes
reculées de cilaos des hommes et des
femmes vivent toujours dans des petits
il est où il cultive la tradition de
leurs parents lointains
pascal hoareau est l'un d'entre eux il
vit dans une petite cabane perdue à plus
de 1300 mètres d'altitude
il s'est spécialisé dans la flore de
cilaos
c'est un tisaneurs on vient le voir des
quatre coins de l'île pour ses conseils
miracle issus des plantes à jcvd si tu
es vraiment stressé ok ça viens tu peux
utiliser se flagellent après stress et
c'est un trait après six ans a servi de
sa purifie sur le temps les il n'y a pas
d'aliment glacial c'est ici très
puissant ça veut dire citant la consoude
au caire avec l'euthanasie
ça nous donnera des plantes idéal que
ces deux plantes là avec ses dépens la
balade est pas propre aux traités
actuellement pour les pucerons
cochenilles en calories si vous avez un
peu au fait ce qu'ils avaient avant nous
mais toujours le patrimoine longtemps
parce que ça me tape a expliqué un petit
peu les gens comment ils vivent et les
gens longtemps roulé ça fait de moi mon
grand père mon papa l'a vécue dans son
hockey avait une peau la cuisine avait
une place non pas de problème
avec fin de vie soit si le reste nous
balader dozois le point de vue le soir
je laisse tranquille
[Musique]
tout la variété de couleurs de verre à
l'intérieur de l'hymne plus bien sûr
noir du volcan
un jeu quand le
l'océan le palais complet c'est
fantastique c'est très très très jeune
et le pouvoir jouer avec la troisième
dimension c'est ça la grande avantage de
faire ce métier de ne pas attaquer mara
au sol limitée à seurre de dimension là
on à la troisième dimension il faut en
profiter
faire un vol commis à vos l'oiseau
cilaos est bel et bien magique et il
faudra se poser pour profiter de toutes
ces plantes aux vertus apaisantes ou
médicinales les coureurs du grand raid
n'auront pas le temps de s'y arrêter
mais profiteront du spectacle qu'ils
offrent à chaque instant se poser n'est
pas dans les intentions de notre
caméraman du ciel il y a encore trop de
choses à découvrir sur cette île trop de
vue imprenable à repérer avant de voir
les coureurs sont emparés à ce niveau
stratégique de la course
les raiders devons ménager leurs efforts
avant d'entreprendre l'ascension lente
et raide du taïbit tu plus de quatre
kilomètres de montée et 820 mètres de
dénivelé avant de rejoindre les salles
asie et le cirque de mafate majestueux
et grandiose du spectacle est sidérant
un des plus beaux au monde
[Musique]
puis la route se dirige tout en descente
au pied des remparts à l'ombre des
acacias
avant de rejoindre marc la mare là c'est
lille est le plus élevé du cirque de
mafate un de ces petits coins de paradis
reculé de la réunion ses habitants sont
fiers de leurs deux épiceries de leur
petite église et de leur école pour
vivre ici il faut aussi être né ou bien
tombé amoureux du site
la directrice de l'école a fait le choix
de s'y installer depuis la réouverture
normalement ils sont 2 normal ils sont à
côté sur une pièce de maternelle font de
la peinture activités de maternelle
comme aujourd'hui aux mains qui a la
varicelle
andrew est tout seul l'indre où
travaillent bien
j'ai la chance d'être en fin de carrière
et de pouvoir choisir de mon poste donc
c'est vraiment un choix c'est ce que
j'ai expliqué aux habitants mon discours
cité c'est un grand honneur pour moi
d'enseignants par la non non je sais la
retraite qui va m'arrêter à mort
[Musique]
et
difficile pour les coureurs de la
diagonale de s'arrêter ici et de
rencontrer les habitants de marla la
fatigue et l' envie d'en finir avec le
grand raid aura raison de leur curiosité
[Musique]
alors que certains mafate et ne sont
jamais sortis de leur cirque et n'ont
jamais vu la mer
d'autres trouvent ici un magnifique
terrain de jeu pour étudier l'évolution
de l'espèce jean michel probst est l'un
d'entre eux il passe ses journées à
observer à recenser les espèces qu'ils
croisent ici un travail de longue
haleine où la patience est une vertu
indispensable
alors en fait ce qui se passe dans le
monde de l'évolution c'est que certains
oiseaux où certains animaux qui sont
arrivés sur l'île n'ont pas changé on va
dire vraiment leurs habitudes donc ils
sont restés les mêmes par contre de
nombreuses espèces retrouver un milieu
complètement différent une nourriture
complètement différentes et donc se sont
transformées c'est un peu compliqué
c'est quelque chose qui se passe sur
souvent des dizaines de milliers
d'années et donc ils ont évolué
différemment et il est apparu sur l'île
de la réunion des espèces on va dire
unique au monde
[Musique]
au cours de ses sorties sur le terrain
jean michel a aussi un rôle de
sensibilisation et d'éducation à
l'environnement et à la faune locale
plutôt discrète ces propos n'est pas mal
en fait on est surpris
il n'y a pas un seul animal on arrive
faut savoir qu'il ya plus de 30 espèces
qui ont disparu à cause de l'homme à la
réunion donc c'est vrai que c'est c'est
un peu désespérant
si on va dire vous étiez venu il ya deux
cents ans vous auriez vu encore on va
dire des perroquets y avait quatre
espèces différentes
il y avait des pigeons qui était assez
gros frugivores il ya des groupes chauve
souris dans les bas il y avait des
flamants roses des aigrettes des
cormorans des canards des oies des ibis
non c'était vraiment des espèces on va
dire nicheuses voilà qui se reproduisait
sur l'île
en fait l'homme a amené énormément de
choses d'ailleurs actuellement il ya
plus d espèces introduites par l'homme
que d'espèces indigènes naturel
mais aujourd'hui à la réunion
beaucoup d'espèces ont disparu et le
braconnage en est la principale cause la
brigade nature veille à ce que cette
pratique s'arrête parfois à ses risques
et périls
on attendait devant un peu ce qu'ils y
entrer ce qu'ils soient en forêt est
généralement assez hélas tout ce qu'ils
se retrouveraient c'est les gens qui ont
qui récupère déjà en forêt les bras
comme
[Musique]
les poussettes
pour la plupart du temps fait de la
sensibilisation des farc mais
quelquefois on va dire il ya vraiment
des problèmes de braconnage assez
important et donc tout seul vin peut pas
agir donc la vraie ya la nature c'est
vraiment un régal un peu chocs quoi qui
permettent d'appréhender les braconniers
que ça chauffe un petit peu trop quoi
[Musique]
les collègues se sont déjà faits foncé
dessus en voiture tentative d'écrasement
j'ai un collègue qui a pris un coup de
sabre dans le mollet donc voilà donc oui
certaines pressions a dit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant il ya un prélèvement très
fort à les populations enfin la
population est de plus en plus
importante
donc la tradition de la chasse aux
tanguay se perpétue en plus il ya un
gain est un appât financier important
puisqu'un temps que ce vent entre 10 et
15 euros donc
ça fait qu'on n'incite un peu plus les
gens allaient braconné voilà et donc ça
se fait aussi bien sur les animaux que
ça se fait sur les végétaux et à côté de
ça on a d'autres types de braconnage
c'est un petit peu aussi culturelle
celle braconnage et collages des oiseaux
la tradition veut aussi que chacun aime
bien avoir une petite cage chez lui avec
un maire le pays
dedans parce que c'est un oiseau qui
chante super bien donc c'est oiseaux et
protégés
il vit un petit peu dans les eaux donc
on le colle on pose sur des bâtons de
de bois de la colle alors ça de la
colonnade soit de la colle de la colle
pour prendre les rats une sorte de glu
et les gens capture les merles pour les
revendre derrière côté de ça on a aussi
des gens qui capturent tout ce qui est
petit oiseau des coûts t-il des petits
becs rose tous ces types d'oiseaux
alors certains pour manger d'autres
également pour garder en volière
[Musique]
comment exprimer ça c'est quelque chose
de profond ça en fait on découvre un
endroit sur terre qui nous semblent
merveilleux quoi et que en fait on m'a
vraiment envie de protéger
donc il ya vraiment on se sent un petit
peu comment on va dire citoyen du monde
quoi et un petit peu tous qui est ici
que ça c'est vraiment extraordinaire
il ya vraiment tout un ensemble de
choses qui font que on est attiré par
cette île pour moi je me sens
réunionnais maintenant
[Musique]
mafate et magique
sans doute parce que l'on ne peut y
accéder qu'après de longues heures de
marche
[Musique]
le cirque est impénétrable et en devient
magique c'est aussi l'impression que
l'on ressent dans les airs basse et son
hélicoptère feront des slaloms à
répétition ici les coureurs sur les
crêtes de mafate
ce sera un moment exceptionnel et pour
être présents à ces moments là un
repérage des lieux est plus
qu'indispensable
je
[Musique]
quatrième étape et plus de 30 kilomètres
de montagnes russes seront à parcourir
dans ce havre de paix délimité par de
hauts remparts de basalte le centième
kilomètre de course n'est pas loin et le
chemin ne cesse d'enchaîner montées et
descentes forêts rivières flanc de
montagne la route sera rude pour les
fous pour les randonneurs aussi mafate
et l'un de ces petits coins perdus qui
se mérite
pour y aller rencontrer ses habitants un
accès possible et de remonter le lit du
plus grand orient de france la rivière
des galets un endroit infranchissable en
période cyclonique à pied ou en 4 4 ce
sont 14 km de rivières à parcourir pour
ceux qui auront choisi le luxe de se
faire ballotter dans tous les sens
personne ne leur reprochera de
s'épargner quelques efforts
avant d'affronter la suite à pied plus
de 8 km de marche
a priori ce n'est pas la mer à boire
mais une montagne à franchir
[Musique]
il y à quelques centaines d'années c'est
ici que les premiers esclaves révoltés
se sont réfugiés et de nombreuses
expéditions punitives n'y ont rien
changé
la forteresse mafate des à protéger pour
devenir leur terre
mafate c'est surtout le nom de l'un des
pionniers morts ici en martyr pour moi
ici c'est plus les escales au niveau des
mares au même niveau dans esclaves en
main mode hippie du coup lille quoi
rached et là je suis en manque de
soutien des chefs et apprennent ans à
qui des reptiliens devant les charmes et
les visées de couru droit d'être pas un
endroit pour les toits et c'est mon
endroit lille avait un peu de la haute
et quads à la casse et mafate s'agit
tous les coins vous ici aussi quelques
maisons aucune voiture une école une
boutique et c'est tout à mafate
on vit loin du reste du monde
présente olalalala cuisine je ne fais le
boire et six et non pas cinq foyers qui
varient d'après mes parents au titre
dans le luxe quoi ils varient d'après
d'après le petit pic de mafate quoi tu
vois là dessus ce maïs là y'a le banc
car tu vois là que ça sert le maïs et du
temps lontan tous les ans achètent et
met le maïs sur le barca pour pouvoir se
fier puis bal maïté c'est vraiment je
sais ce que tu essaies les lie quoi le
plan des lives et
[Musique]
la vie paisible suit son cours mais ici
il n'y a pas de travail
le rmi comme seule ressource les
mafatais louent leurs parcelles à
l'office national des forêts en ayant la
certitude qu'ils ne seront jamais
propriétaires de leur maison
tout ce qui est ici est venu à dos
d'homme ou par hélicoptère
180 euros les 5 minutes de vol de quoi
renforcer un peu plus la sensation
d'isolement et parfois d'oubli
quand on dit voilà toi tu faisais quoi
nous mentant nous manque tant on peut
pas payer à vie sans rien du tout moi je
vais payer sur un temps de 2h sur ces
temps où sont présents à pau ce 16 de 15
ans le terrain est à moi je peux mettre
ma fille ou mon fils ici comme toute mon
enfance ont tout le monde quand on droit
tu vois mais ne peut pas ni abcès palais
n'acceptant que voilà que les paillettes
rouler à vicois envie sans garantir bas
on est toujours on est toujours pour moi
le score je m'étais fini on est toujours
le sommet small & ball frusques la
valette et demi sur le papier quoi j'ai
sur le papier on agit sur les chaînes
angoisse
en fait c'est une ville où là que des
passages piétons il n'y a pas de groupe
le
[Musique]
à l'heure où la cote réunionnaise vite
avec le haut débit et l'adsl les
mafatais continue parfois malgré eux à
faire vivre la mémoire de leurs ancêtres
les premiers esclaves libres
[Musique]
l'homme s'est ainsi installée dans les
rares espaces plats et stable coffre
mafate sans toutefois dénaturer la
nature des paysages chaotique de
l'intérieur de l'île qui conserve ses
caractéristiques originelles
à l'heure du grand raid mafate dévoile
son coeur raidillon dénivelé sentiers
forêt la route est longue avant
d'arriver au stade de saint-denis
[Musique]
sa cheffe de mafate
les touristes eux n'auront pas tous le
courage de franchir le cap et de
pénétrer dans l'antre de l'immense
mafate
ça fait depuis une bonne dizaine
d'années qu'on a vraiment une politique
où on met en avant les sentiers de
randonnée et notamment avec des courses
de montagne puisqu'ici on a pas mal de
courses de montagne de très grands
convois de montagne d'un grand raid
c'est aussi l'une des cause le plus dur
au monde il paraît et grâce à tous ces
événements là on commence à mieux
connaître ateliers de l'isle
bonjour bonjour ça va on voit là un
petit peu l'itinéraire qu'on va faire on
va démarrer du sentier pour atteindre
une lettre de roche plate dans mafate
700 m de dénivelé négatif 7 va falloir
penser au retour le lendemain ça va être
du positif le lendemain faudra bien
ménagé ses efforts aujourd'hui pour
pouvoir y arriver demain retour
allez c'est parti
[Musique]
à 35 ans yanis et guide de randonnée
mafate et d'origine il connaît tous les
sentiers de la réunion comme sa poche
mais c'est préférer ce sont les siens
ceux qui l'ont vu faire ses premiers pas
ceux de mafate
aujourd'hui ils guident marion et cathy
deux randonneuses au coeur du site de
mafate à roche plate cinq heures de
marche des décors fabuleux avec au
passage des petits cadeaux que seuls les
mafate et savent reconnaître qu est-ce
que c'est ça les petites phrases
enfin ça ressemble plus à de l'enfant
braz nous l'écran on appelait ça des
fraises des bois c'est riche en vitamine
c ça peut aider ceux qui sont motivés ça
c'est bon à boucher les traits relation
homme nature nous donc c'est un peu
moins sucrés comme les fraises
du continent
voilà on est arrivé à l'entrée de lille
est aux platines il est dans mafate
1 il est c'est un lieu habité sur un
plateau de montagne c'est une ligne dans
une île voilà une quinzaine d'années à
peine que lille est reçoit les
randonneurs chaque année plus nombreux
alors pour gérer les réservations
on a dû s'organiser tous les touristes
du monde entier qui viennent mafate pour
les accueils à la traditionnelle quoi
les structures ces petits bungalows mais
bhl est équipé à la créole et puis les
touristes et il ya une émission comme
celle de quoi
donc là vous agrandissez la lui j'ai
fait les interroge de manière j'ai fait
des nombreux palais des mille aux
sanitaires et les fosses septiques
comme ici tout est plus compliqué
qu'ailleurs c'est par hélicoptère que
l'on a dû amener un bulldozer mais en
fait on est venus l'année dernière une
première fois et il y avait il y avait
beaucoup moins l'infrastructure pour le
tourisme c'est vrai que ça s'est
beaucoup développé cette dernière année
là et c'est un c'est plus confortable
c'est mais bon d'un autre côté c'est
moins la fête c'est un petit peu plus
sur balisé aux normes
voilà on prend conscience de tout ce
qu'on a à l'intérieur de l'île
on est bientôt dont on n'est aujourd'hui
pas nationale on a beaucoup d'espèces
endémiques
donc tout ça aujourd'hui les autorités
ont fait confiance m'a qu'il fallait
protéger que c'était aussi un atout un
atout pour pouvoir adhérer les touristes
développer la randonnée faire une aide
matérielle est vraiment
petit à petit mafate succombent aux
sirènes économique du tourisme
[Musique]
et pendant que les nouveaux randonneurs
continuent leur chemin l'hélico du grand
raid poursuit lui aussi sa route des
images fantastiques sont enregistrés
dans la caméra de basse elles serviront
à de nombreux reportages pour faire
découvrir les splendeurs de la réunion
costaud très costaud
le cirque de mafate pour le raider
laissera des traces
à tout jamais mais la route n'est pas
fini ils aborderont le dernier gros
morceau de leur périple
l'ascension de dos d'âne jusqu'à la
plaine d'affouches au fil des kilomètres
le sentier se rétrécit à flanc de
falaise mafate s'éloigne dans le dos des
coureurs qui progresse vers le nord de
l'île
[Musique]
ils sont à présent au coeur de la plaine
d'affouches et du piton fougères au lieu
de la faune sauvage
cette forêt indigène abrite bien des
espèces animales et végétales
encore faut-il les débusquer des
associations de protection de la nature
regroupe des passionnés qui inventorie
et consacrent leur temps à l'étude des
espèces autochtones de la réunion écoute
ça fait un petit moment que je suis
cette population-là la plaine
d'affouches ouais donc je viens avec mes
fiches un petit peu d'identification et
j'essaie de retrouver les individus
qu'on a préalablement capturer c'était
bien donc là bas j'ai retrouvé un mal
ah ouais donc que j'ai pu l'identifier
grâce à sa photo alors je regarde il est
calé normalement ah ouais même si le
temps il est un peu il est un peu plus
vieux ils sont quand même
il est pas très actif mais sortant même
ouais bon c'est vrai que c'est pas très
favorable depuis tout jeune j'ai été
baigné dans ce dans ce monde végétal
j'ai commencé comme tous les comme tous
les gamins à suivre les parents et puis
en fait qu on entend aussi des
braconniers
parce que eux aussi les anciens ils nous
donnent aussi leur façon de voir et puis
bon on essaye de leur expliquer bon ben
voila vous aviez des pratiques à
l'époque aujourd'hui si vous voulez
préserver la la la forêt ou bien soin
les animaux on va changer un petit peu
la pratique où on va on va leur donner
des ans des éléments et puis c'est des
échanges qui se font très bien et à ce
moment là les gens se comprennent on
n'est pas qu'on n'ait pas but et on
n'est pas fermé on sait que bon ben ils
ont peut-être des besoins nous on essaye
de leur dire ben les face à ça il ya
aussi des enjeux au niveau de la
préservation
donc on essaye de trouver un compromis
quand il est en fait d'avoir un gros
fruits rouges
d'où son nom puis aux plus récentes que
pure essence rouge up
on a ici sur une petite île comme la
réunion une grande diversité il faut là
il faut la préserver faso entre
guillemets aux espèces qui sont
introduits c'est 850 en gros d'espèces
indigènes face à 2000 espèces qui ont
été introduites le combat il est déloyal
aujourd'hui la plaine d'affouches reste
à l'écart des pressions humaines car son
accès est difficile toutefois trouver
des espèces indigènes demande de
s'aventurer de plus en plus loin au
coeur de la forêt on va prendre
regardez on va prendre la tiens on va
prendre les mesures et mettre 30 à peu
près
regardez un coup s'il ya des s'il ya des
fruits il ya des fruits
je suis lassé pandanus pente anus
sylvestris silvestrini ce qui veut dire
des bois
ici on a le feu du monde amis sylvestris
beaucoup plus petit que les autres à
maturité ça va ça va se détacher
ça va tomber au niveau du sol ça va
pourrir donc l'idéal ce serait de
revenir de collecter les fruits
récupérer les graines et ensuite les
mettre en culture pour le tard voilà
pour plus tard les réimplanter c'est
peut-être une des causes de sa rareté
au niveau de la forêt c'est que les
anciennes faille reste là et ça leur
fait un bon bon abri ouais si on
retrouverait d eux ce serait bien je
vous imagine et de découvrir une plante
encore aujourd'hui ou découvrir demain
peut-être un nouvel insecte ou un nouvel
animal ce serait cesser ces magnifiques
vous imaginez sur une petite île comme
la réunion puis à lui dans l'océan non
quand la chance d'avoir encore ce genre
de découverte
aujourd'hui on est dans un tournant il
faut pas louper le coche je vous dis
hein je reprends l'exemple de maurice
aujourd'hui à maurice il ne reste plus
que 2 % de végétation indigène
autochtone on a aussi la chance d'avoir
30 % il faut il faut il faut il faut
travailler il faut le préserver
parce que sinon on la réunion perdra son
identité sa spécificité
parce que bon c'est bien beau on a la
mer mais on a aussi et on a encore la
chance d'avoir une forêt qui est
originaire c'est à dire des espèces qui
nous vont exister qu'à la réunion vous
ne verrez jamais à en métropole en
australie vous verrez qu'à l'art in et
c'est ça l'enjeu de demain si on veut si
on veut garder
notre richesse les espèces exotiques
introduites par l'homme parfois
envahissante menace en effet la faune
originel jusque dans les endroits les
plus inaccessibles
l'unique précieuse et fragile
l'île de la réunion fait partie de ces
hauts lieux de la biodiversité que
l'homme se doit de préserver des univers
aussi exceptionnel une course de légende
basse aura la lourde tâche de restituer
au mieux les plus belles vues de l'île
tout en haut avec son hélicoptère
il sera un témoin privilégié de la façon
dont l'homme veut tenter d'apprivoiser
la nature d'une île volcanique
vu une partie du monde les meilleurs
endroits on fait toujours les
plus jamais entré dans par exemple d'un
visage petersburg
plusieurs fois 2
[Musique]
pour les raiders la diagonale des fous
touchera ici à sa fin ce défi restera
une expérience exceptionnelle à jamais
gravé dans leur mémoire
quel que soit leur classement ils
garderont certainement dans leurs
souvenirs communs la nature originelle
de cette île à grand spectacle véritable
sanctuaire de l'exploit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]